[Music]
hello everyone
so we'll continue our discussion of uh
the principal stresses which we had
started in our
previous class so to very quickly recall
we had spent some time
discussing in detail uh the importance
of
these three coefficients the i1 the i2
and the i3 which appear
in this equation which basically comes
from if you go back to the previous
slide
from this determinant now
again to to recap the sigma that we see
here
the sigma that we see here the same
sigma
so this is uh since this is a
this an algebraic equation of degree 3
we will in general end up with three
distinct roots
uh it can happen that may be two of
those roots are
[Music]
maybe maybe one root or two roots are
equal to each other so
[Music]
so look at those special cases as part
of the problem
sheet but let's say that we have these
three distinct roots
and each of those
roots the values
the different values of sigma they will
be the principal stresses
okay now correspondingly the
each each sigma will give rise to
a set of n1 n2 and n3 so suppose
we obtain as solutions uh sigma
one sigma two and sigma three then
corresponding to sigma one we'll have n
one a two and n three one set of n one
and
three then for sigma two we'll have
another set of n one n two n three
and for sigma 3 we'll have another set
of n 1 n 2 and n 3.
so uh just like in any eigenvalue
problem
now each of those three sets of n 1 n 2
and
n 3 corresponding to each of the three
different values of sigma 1 sigma 2 and
sigma
3 will be referred to as the principal
directions
in the language of the eigenvalue
problem you recognize
that the therefore that the principal
directions
are nothing but the eigenvector vectors
of this
problem we have also discussed
that these are invariant values
okay because we understand from the
physical situation that the principal
stresses at a particular point
is a physical truth and it should not
depend on the mathematical
representation
okay so no matter what the individual
values
of the different stress components at
that particular point may be
given by different values of this sigma
1 1 sigma 2 2 and sigma 3
3 the special combination in which they
appeared
in each of these um these expressions
for i1 i2 and i3
must be a very special combination and
so
they must be in variance okay so we
write this here
that
that i1 i2 and i3
are specifically they are referred to as
the stress in variance
[Music]
this is very very important they are
referred to as the stress ingredients
okay so uh going forward what we'll do
is
we'll discuss a couple of very important
facts uh
associated with this eigenvalue problem
uh i believe
uh uh you've learned you've already
learned this back in your first year
mathematics
but still it will be useful to to recap
two of those facts as part of this
eigenvalue problem as
applied to this to the stress chapter
okay so uh
so i'm trying something new uh in
today's lecture
so whenever i have to have to put in
some text
try to type it in let's see how that
works
anyway so so as i mentioned
uh we would be we'll be talking about
two important facts associated with the
principle stresses
and and as they appeared in the
eigenvalue problem
so the first fact uh
is so fact one
is that
the if we have a matrix
which uh has as its elements
uh real uh values and the overall matrix
happens to be symmetric then the
eigenvalues of that
matrix must be real it's a very
important fact
so the eigenvalues of
a real
symmetric matrix
[Music]
must be real and this has direct
application in our study of stress
because
we know that since the stress components
since the stress components
[Music]
are real and
and the stress matrix
is symmetric therefore
the principal stresses which are
the principal stresses which are nothing
but the eigenvalues of the stress matrix
therefore the principal stresses
must be real okay so the conclusion
seems almost like a foregone conclusion
of course the principal stresses must
have real values but you understand that
this is very much consistent
with uh with
with the eigenvalue problem as far as
the mathematics go
the next fact uh back to
is that uh suppose uh
so so again speaking generally in terms
of an eigenvalue problem
so for in an eigenvalue problem if we
have the eigenvalues to be
distinct so suppose they are all having
different values
then uh it follows that the eigenvectors
must be perpendicular to each other or
in the
or more sophisticated language they must
be orthogonal
orthogonal to each other so
so the eigenvectors
corresponding to distinct
eigenvalues uh
must be perpendicular to each other
okay so uh what it basically means is
that
so if the
values of the principal
[Music]
stresses are distinct
[Music]
then the principal directions
are perpendicular to each other that is
what it means
uh for the correct current context
okay so these are the two important
facts now
what is the use of these two facts
well the users that you notice that
if the principal directions are indeed
perpendicular to each other
then the situation is not quite
different from
is not at all different from what you
have in the case of your general
coordinate axis because coordinate axes
are also perpendicular to each other and
here we are having this
situation where the principle directions
are perpendicular to each other
so this motivates us to
think of it in this this way suppose
suppose uh we choose our coordinate axis
to be oriented along these mutually
perpendicular
principle directions then what will
happen now this might seem like a very
uh very artificially concocted type of
question
like just because they are perpendicular
to each other like what is the
motivation for this
and you'll see in a moment what is the
motivation like
things become really nice and clean
if we do that so what will
uh so this this naturally leads us to
the next topic of discussion
uh
[Music]
which is
[Music]
the state of stress are
referred to principal directions
okay so
so if we do that what is going to happen
the state of stress
so when i say the state of stress i
basically mean
that what will be the values of the
stress components
when we are sitting at a particular
point we have already seen
that if you sit at a particular point
you orient your plane along any
arbitrary direction
uh you will end up with these various
components like sigma 1 1 sigma 1 2
sigma 1 3
etc etc what will happen to those
components
if we we refer to uh
if we refer to uh is a situation
where the coordinate axes are uh
are oriented along the principal
directions so that's uh that's what we
are going to write down here
that
here we orient our coordinate axis
along the principal directions
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so you think for a moment what we are
doing here
we know that
uh if we go back to the
to this slide if we go back to this
slide
we've already mentioned that the
principal plane okay this is referred to
as the principal plane
when the situation is such that the
traction vector
is parallel to the n-hat
okay so basically uh the plane
uh on which the principal stresses are
lying
so if we if you're indeed
orienting our coordinate axis
along those principle directions it
basically means that
two of these coordinate axes would be
lying along the plane
and one of these coordinate axis would
be lying along the direction
of the unit outward normal which also
happens for this
very special plane to be along the
principle direction
now if that is so then what do you think
will happen to the stress components
you understand that these stress
components are nothing but
various components of this traction
vector
so first of all tell me about so you
think about
the tn component
well on the plane
on the plane where you actually have the
existence of such
principle stresses
is it not true that this t superscript n
is nothing but one of the values of
[Music]
of this problem is one of the answers to
this problem or one of the roots of this
problem
so it is uh so it is actually so we if
we had said earlier that
it would be sick the roots would be
sigma one sigma to sigma three
and if we are actually considering a
plane
[Music]
which is having a situation that the t
vector is parallel to this thing then
the tn
is indeed one of those roots sigma 1
sigma 2 sigma 3
but what about the shear stresses so if
the t vector
is parallel to the n hat then
the then then
there will be simply no component along
this plane
okay so we can quickly draw this
diagram instead of just discussing it
like this
that suppose we have this plane
and we have our
our unit outward normal like this
and the plane is such that the traction
vector
is also
like this okay
so what we say is that this can only
happen
when this is a principal plane
[Music]
it must also be true that this
maybe i can draw over this
just to make it clear
so this n hat
this will be a principal direction
[Music]
okay this
[Music]
t-vector okay so this is the t
vector and you also understand that
along this
you have uh the
the entire magnitude to be equal to e
n and since the unit vector along this
is
n hat it is just like this okay
and we have already noted that this is
nothing but
the principal stress itself okay
and you understand that along this plane
the ts value will be equal to zero so we
can actually write this down
so whether it is t s or t t uh
t s equal to t t is going to be zero
here
okay this is very very important so you
will not have any shear
components now you understand that
now what we are doing is we are
orienting our
coordinate axis like this so our
coordinate axis you understand that
uh it is it is it is like this
so maybe our x1 is along like this
and uh
[Music]
so
maybe x2 is like this x3 is like this
there is no restriction on us
to say that the x1 has to be like this
it could have
very well be the case that x2 is along
this parallel to this n hat now you
understand that this
x2 3 plane okay the plane containing
this x 2 x 3 axis
it is parallel to this to this plane
okay so now we can write it down
here that
note the
[Music]
x2 x3 plane
the way that we have drawn here the
plane here
will be parallel
to the principal plane
okay which is this plane okay we can
actually write this here
principal plane is parallel to the x2 x3
for this particular for the
for the particular way that we have set
it up had we
instead chosen the x1 and x2 to be here
and x3 to be here
then of course the principal plane would
have been parallel to the x1 x2
okay now with this understanding what we
can we say about the stress components
so
suppose okay suppose the so
so if we go back quickly and look at it
suppose the roots of this equation
are sigma 1 sigma 2 and sigma 3 okay so
sometimes this is referred to as
the characteristic equation
so
sigma q minus i1 sigma square
plus i 2 sigma
minus i 3 is equal to 0 suppose
the roots are
sigma 1 superscript
sigma 2 superscript and sigma 3.
okay suppose these are the roots and as
we have said that
[Music]
these need to be distinct okay these
three roots need to be distinct in order
that the principal directions are
perpendicular to each other
uh going by this fact two which you have
written down here
that if the values of the principal
stresses are distinct then the principal
directions are perpendicular to each
other
so we are working under that assumption
because if sigma 1 sigma 2 and sigma 3
are distinct then we have this situation
and then this tn value
this generic sigma that we have noted
down here it will be
either one of these three sigma 1 sigma
2 and sigma 3
this sigma will be any one of these
three values
okay then how the stress stress tensor
is going to look like
so you can see here that what will be
the value
so uh since our x1 is like this
okay since our x1 is like this what will
be the value of the sigma 1 1
so sigma 1 1 is basically the traction
component
on the plane which is perpendicular to
the x1 plane
so what is that plane it is nothing but
this parallel
to this uh this principle plane itself
this principle plane is perpendicular to
the x1 axis
so we have our plane right so
the sigma 1 1 is the stress component on
a plane
which is perpendicular to the x 1 axis
and it is the traction component along
the
x direction so it is nothing but this
component itself which is nothing but
this tn component itself
which is also f which is also the sigma
so
what we can say is that
this is this sigma is going to be one of
these
roots okay let's say that it is the
sigma
one okay it is very much possible that
it could be i mean in terms of values it
could be any one of these but
we are just keeping things uh
neat and clean here for the purpose of
organization
so what about the sigma 2 2
so just like we have taken the principal
direction
like this so another principle direction
would be perpendicular to this
and we we are orienting our
we are going to orient another
coordinate axis maybe the x two axis
along that direction
so and if we do that then it is uh
what we are going to end up with is a
principal plane
which is such that it is perpendicular
to the x two axis so the sigma
and the traction component which is
along the
x two direction that will be sigma 2 2
so the sigma 2 2
here we can say it is equal to sigma
2 and similar is the case for the third
direction
and the third plane so we are
good here now what about the other two
components the sigma one two component
and the sigma one three component
now the sigma one two component you
understand is
coming back to this plane the traction
component
which is lying
on a plane which is perpendicular to the
x1 axis
but which is oriented along the
direction x2
but on this plane we have already noted
that there will be no
traction component along this plane that
value is equal to zero
so the sigma one two is equal to zero
similarly if you consider a shear
component of the stress
along the along the direction three so
that is basically the sigma one three
that is also going to be
zero similar is the case for sigma two
one
so the the the element sitting here
strictly speaking is sigma 2 1
we understand that that must be equal to
0
but you can also try to think of it in a
very
clear clear headed fashion by note by
noting that other plane that would
that would have been present here
oriented perpendicular to the
x2 axis and on that plane also there
would have been no component
of the traction along that plane itself
which means that the sigma 2 1 has to be
necessarily 0 also similar is the case
here or sigma 2 3
and we can immediately write down the
other
things here also so this is the state of
stress
okay so this is when we say that the
state of stress referred to principal
directions
this is basically what we mean this is
an extremely extremely important concept
uh especially because uh
if if you are free to choose
your your uh your coordinate axis
and you happen to choose it like this uh
where when you orient the coordinate
axis along the principle directions
then you see how nicely this has shaped
up okay only the diagonal elements are
present
and the non-diagonal the octagonal
elements are all zero
okay so uh so this is a rather
short topic but uh an extremely
extremely
uh important one uh as far as
your understanding of the whole
principle stresses concept
is concerned all right we'll continue
with our discussion of stresses in the
next part of the
lecture now thank you very much